also eigentlich ist die energiepolitik
nicht in ein direktes thema ich bin
verkehrspolitischer sprecher der
unionsfraktion
aber mich nervt es furchtbar dass die
energiepreise unglaublich steigen dass
sich die explosionsartig erhöhen jetzt
kann man sagen hier war es ja auch mit
schuld mit den zertifikaten das waren so
circa acht cent pro liter benzin oder
diesel aber wir haben ja jetzt zum
vergleich vom vom letzten jahr bei man
diesel ca 50 50 cent steigerungen bei 51
cent bildungs preise explodieren was das
anbelangt und dann wenn ich dann noch
höhere das nord stream zwei nicht in
betrieb gehen soll oder der kohleabbau
schon acht jahre früher beendet werden
soll also die kohleverstromung haben sie
sagen wo gehen wir hin als industrieland
deutschland wir verteuern alles in
unserem land ist denke ich ist ein thema
das ärgert mich furchtbar wo die reise
hingeht dann muss gegengesteuert herein
ich hätte sie als person abbinden doch
muss ich sagen durchaus lustig über das
was sie jetzt gerade sagen also wenn wir
jetzt einen monat zurück gehen dann ist
doch genau ihre regierung abgewählt
worden nach 16 jahren angela merkel
regierung gibt es nun wahrscheinlich
eine andere koalition der die union also
auch die cs und nicht mehr beteiligt ist
und wenn man sich die zahlen anschaut
dann ist zum beispiel unter angela
merkel der strompreis um 68 prozent
gestiegen in ihrer kanzlerschaft wir
haben jetzt am ende der ära angela
merkel also auch am ende der ära cdu/csu
einen benzinpreis von dem 66 prozent
eines liter preises in die staatskasse
fließt also zwei drittel das heißt sich
jetzt hinzustellen und zu sagen ja rot
grün wird uns arm machen nur die ampel
wurden zu machen das heißt ich gelinde
gesagt doch für eine haltet den dieb
methode es war die regierung merkel cdu
csu mal mit der fdp die meiste zeit mit
der spd die energie in deutschland
massiv verteuert hat und wenn wir uns
angucken was auch nächstes jahr droht
dann ist das natürlich ein beschluss der
schwarz roten bundesregierung gewesen
diesen co2 preis in den nächsten jahren
sukzessive anzuheben also das ist
wirklich jetzt ziehen auf ein gegner der
in ihren eigenen reihen gesessen hat
nein so stimmt es nicht
zudem soll also der spritpreis letztes
jahr jahreswechseln lagen wie beim
diesel ungefähr bei einem euro lassen
sie uns einmal über den steuer und
letztes jahr ja das wechselt naja aber
trotzdem
aber in silber hause wir wissen aber
auch dass rot-grün für die benzinpreis
genauso wenig kann es geht immer um den
steueranteil und den hat rot grün gelben
genauso wie die schwarzen unter angela
merkel in der hand wie co2 zertifikate
angesprochen und ich habe vorhin in der
einleitung auch gesagt durch die co2
zertifikaten ist der sprit um ungefähr
auch zentraler wurden jetzt zimmer aber
nicht bei 8 sind mehr sondern bei 50 60
cent mehr und wenn du auf der autobahn
bist bist du bei fast zwei euro also da
hängt schon viel ist auch warum polen
sondern eine rabatt ist aber wir haben
die steuern nein wir haben die steuern
deshalb auch nicht erhöht die steuern
wurden nicht erhöht die steuern sind
mehr geworden und deshalb müssen wir
jetzt gegensteuern was den strom
angelangt gebe ich ihnen recht sagen sie
ganz normal ihren punkt was genau macht
rot grün jetzt teurer was sie nicht
selbst vorgemacht haben ich hab mir
gesagt rot grün noch teurer ich habe
gesagt mich regen spritzt und
energiepreise auf und wir müssen
gegensteuern und da ist der falsche weg
wenn ich sage ich will nur zwei nicht
und verknappte energie oder ich
beschleunige den kohleausstieg noch mehr
und wir sind angewiesen auch auf
energieimporte aus dem ausland und die
uns da in unserem preis diktieren können
das ist für uns ja der atomausstieg hat
am ende aber die bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel zusammen mit den csu spitzen
durch gebracht hätte man das thema nord
stream 20 jahren hätte man das thema
stromimporte nicht gehabt also auch das
geht muss man sagen auf die rechnung von
cdu bfl
14 wollte
der menschen in deutschland
wir wollen es nicht unhöflich sein und
dieses faszinierende ping
[Gelächter]
sprechen aber ich musste dann wird diese
stimme der vernunft hier als bayer muss
ich jetzt loben sie haben richter rainer
das ist ein riesiges ärgernis und diese
steigenden preise sind natürlich die
folge einen neuen eine energiewende
wir wollen jetzt nicht sagen wer daran
schuld ist aber nämlich ziemlich alle
mitgemacht haben als relativ kopflos das
ist die folge der energiewende der
klimapolitik ich habe heute gewesen in
der frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung am
gipfel in glasgow un-klimagipfel drohe
jetzt die für sieben fassung der
klimamaßnahmen wir haben also eine
hyperinflation des klimawandels und was
wir hier beobachten
ich würde das noch zuspitzen was sie
gesagt haben ist im grunde auch die
ausplünderung des mittelstands und jene
leute die durch diese maßnahmen am
stärksten getroffen werden das sind
nämlich die ärmeren leute denen nimmt
man die mobilität weg warum verteuert
ihnen das wohnen man vertraut ihnen das
essen man will ihnen sagen was sie noch
im kühlschrank drin haben dürfen frei
steffen wir nicht mehr leisten müssen
alle genießen insekten essen sie karten
essen das haben wir alles erlebt das
kommt jetzt auf uns zu in der schweiz
trainieren uns die bundesämter dass wir
2025 eine stromlücke haben wir müssen
jetzt einen kerzen vorrat anlegen damit
wir unser kaiser von die auf der kerze
machen können das wird uns gelingen aber
dass sich als serie uhr tschuldigung das
ist klinische wahnsinn das ist suizid
der industriegesellschaft und da muss
man einfach in aller deutlichkeit
gegensteuer geben ich unterstütze das
und ich finde das lieber spät als nie
das anzutragen ich glaube wir sind auf
einem energiepolitischen blindflug und
der hohen ist dass die sich da als die
sozialsten geben die ganzen sozial
kämpfen und die grünen und die roten das
sind die die diese soziale spaltung
vorantreiben das ist die größte soziale
spannungen ein sprung ein spruch letzten
16 jahre hat bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel cdu ich sind langweilig die
aktion also
wer kein grund zur freude über den
gesprächen energiepolitik was wir da
jetzt erleben ist glaube ich einfach der
realität schaut ja wir haben jetzt
2010 mit der entscheidung die
atomenergie die kernenergie nicht
weiterzuführen die atomkraftwerke
abzuschalten
das war ausfluss einer ideologie
getriebenen politik und ich glaube jede
ideologie getriebene politik wird sich
irgendwann den realitäten stellen müssen
früher oder später in dem fall ist es
jetzt zehn oder elf jahre später
passiert energiepolitik spielt immer in
einem dreiklang da geht es um
versorgungssicherheit und bezahlbarkeit
und umweltverträglichkeit
wenn man eines dieser ziele absolut
setzt um so kam es mir ein bisschen vor
dann kriegt man irgendwann ein problem
zumal in einer hoch entwickelten
industriegesellschaft für die
bundesrepublik wo wir mal auf
stromversorgung auf eine sichere
stromversorgung und auf eine bezahlbare
stromversorgung angewiesen sind und das
ist jetzt das disaster vor dem wir
stehen und das wird sich nicht so
schnell auch nicht mit auch nicht mit
nord stream 2 übrigens und gewiss nicht
mit dem ausbau der erneuerbaren lösen
lassen aber es ist ganz wichtiger punkt
mit stream 2 während nämlich der gips
oder verrücktheit dass man da noch diese
entlein die wird dann auch noch
verteufelt woher soll dann die energie
kommt wollen wir dann eben augen
verbrennen oder wollen wir den strom
quasi ich weiß auch nicht yoga wäre ich
sehe aber im himmel herunter kommt das
ist einfach den song tik wie sie in dem
bereich der energie esoterik kommt dann
aus atomkraftwerken
ja aber das ist doch genau und da sind
wir doch auf dem scherbenhaufen von
angela merkels klimapolitik und das kann
man glaube ich gar nicht häufig genug
und laut genug sagen und da haben wir
keinen widerspruch nein da sind wir ganz
klar einer meinung überhaupt
unter leitung der gegengift gegen diesen
klimaschwindel oder haben sie noch
einmal selbst verstehen aber wir
haben auch dass über das thema kernkraft
auch in dieser runde aber auch bei uns
im blatt und online immer wieder darüber
geschrieben und zu sagen 80 prozent der
bundesbürger wollten den ausstieg aber
genau das was gerade ihm angesprochen
wurde genau das hätte man alles sehen
können wir haben im ersten halbjahr ein
er beim strom 40 prozent kernkraft und
kohle kraftwerken 40 prozent jetzt
sollen wir aussteigen aus der kernkraft
komplett ende nächsten jahres und aus
der kohle idealer weise das kann ja
sogar aus klimaschutz gesichtspunkten
sogar noch sinn machen im jahr dann am
besten 20 30 also innerhalb der nächsten
neun jahre berauben wir uns fast 50
prozent der aktuell in deutschland
nötigen stromherstellung
ich will nicht da wieder drauf herkomm
aber das wusste weiß man alles sie
wissen das auch ganz genau und jetzt zu
sagen nur weil in japan ein tsunami ein
kernkraftwerk in die luft geschossen hat
weil es dort ein erdbeben gab schalten
wir in mitteleuropa wo drumherum ganz
viele kernkraftwerke laufen alle
kernkraftwerke hat die logik erschließt
sich mir bis heute nicht die
bundeskanzlerin hieß damals angela
merkel sie wird daher weiter
verantwortlich seid für genauso
geschichte aber die probleme die finden
in der zeit nach es wurde ja damals eine
ethikkommission ins leben gerufen um die
energiewende zu beschließen eine
ethikkommission da saßen wir bischöfe
als als leute aus der energiewirtschaft
und das ist das ergebnis das wir jetzt
davon habe ich nur einen satz machen zu
führen gute nach die gute nachricht ist
diese runde und die kostenwahrheit dass
das jetzt auf die lebenskosten
durchschlägt wird bei den leuten eine
bewusstseinsveränderung durchführen weil
sie im eigenen portemonnaie und kommt
dann sind die leute nämlich bei diesem
bischöflichen war dieser klima ist
ich hab das war doch ganz gut diskussion
als sehr gut empfunden und man sieht was
das wäre für brennendes thema ist und
dass man uns an das thema raum machen
müssen und sie haben es gesagt sollten
wir vielleicht die gegenfrage sollten
wir nicht wieder in die diskussion
kernkraftwerke sagen wir können würden
sie die diskussion beginnen wir reden
vom klimaschutz natürlich wissen wir um
den radioaktiven abfall aber aus den
klimaschutz anmeldungen das hat übrigens
ein budget im wahlkampf gesagt hätten
wir vorher eigentlich die
kohlekraftwerke abschalten müssen und
dann wenn wir genügend nachwachsende
energie in horn windräder und was sie
noch alles das vielleicht auch grund ist
dann erst mal einer sagen sie ganz gut
einmal ganz fordert einmal ganz kurz
sagen das heißt in der oppositionsrolle
muss die union über das thema kernkraft
neu debattieren auch über die frage muss
man zur kernkraft in deutschland
zurückkehren ich denke wenn es um die
energiepreise geht dann darf es kein
denkverbot geben es geht um die menschen
und um die energieversorgung in unserem
land